il est irremplaçable sur scène et au
cinéma et ne compte pas en rester là je
reçois l'un de nos comédiens les plus
populaires le Tony Truant et truculant
Michel
Galabru qu'est-ce que je suis contente
de te voir TU on s'est pas vu depuis
plusieurs années non quand même on s'est
vu de temps en temps pas oui mais enfin
ça fait quand même de 3 ans qu'on s par
ah mais oui bien 2 3 ans oui bonsoir
tous les deux bonsoir Claude jeansac
bonsoir Michel Galabru quelle
retrouvaille quand même pour est jolie
ah là là oh bah attendezv écoute on peut
pas être vous arrêterin oh il est d'une
élégance r ch de votre partin c'est pas
joli jolie que essayez de me
tortilltiller moi il y a pas langue de
bois croyez que vous étiez elle est
toujours extraordinaire
mais m'excuser
comme le grand Charles c'estit mieux
autre fois
oh pour vous auss oui il y a pas de
salon c'est tous non pour nous tousi
aussi n'importe quoioroi n'importe
qui alors de de bons souvenirs ensemble
sur ces tournages vous
interpréteriezvous donc laadjudant
Gerbert et vous la fameuse Josepha voilà
madame Cruchot madame Cruchot après
après épouse de Louis de funess voilà
c'est ça ma biche il vous surnommez ma
biche ma biche oui ça d aller bien oui
comment était-elle Claude quel souvenir
vous avez gardé d'elle mich bah c'était
c'était la belle fille quoi c'était la
belle grosesse quoi ah vous la draguiez
je sais pas je sais pas parce que je me
rendais bien compte que j'étais pas à la
hauteur quoi vous savez ah oui Chantz ça
ça se sent plutôt d'aller vers l'échec
je je contournais l'obstacle vous voyez
je je j'étais aimable j'étais gentil
j'étais oh c'était un amour de l'amour
voz elle dit mais attention pas plus
loin
voyez tandis que comment
queedoutable comment ça redoutable
tombeuse ah oui tombeuse non non il
pouvait rien était belle était belle la
beauté c'est la beauté il y a rien à
faire les femmes les femmes ne se
rendent pas compte de la puissance
qu'elles ont quand elles sont comment
dirais-je
comestibles une femme comestible c'est
une
puissance donc oui c'est pas très joli
comme mot mich alors là vous rabaissez
vous rabaissz leis conférence sur c'est
pas de la viande n rien à voir c'est mal
vu ça veut dire qu'elle est
c'est tout c'est bien ce que je
dis c'est clair pour lui c'est
énorme c'est
considérable parce que quand une femme n
pas c'est un échec benah dites
donc c'est terrible ce que vous dites là
vous rendez compte pour toutes les
personnes qui n'auraient pas une beauté
comme ça évidente ah ben oui mais
qu'est-ce que ça c'est la vie moi aussi
j'étais pas beau et vous savez quand
vous êtes bel homme aussi ça va bien
aussi hein ça va bien ça marche bien
tout est facilité et ça vous a chagriné
ENF ça vous aou est complexé est
complexé mais parce que vous vous n'avez
pas vous vous pouvez pas c'est très
difficile de de faire sa cour quand on n
pas sûr quand on a une gueule un peu un
peu de Reille quoi c'est une vieille
expression qui date de mathisalem ah ben
oui jeexcuse enfin je suis de cette
époque là je
m'acuse mais j'avais personne comme ça
comprenez ce que veux dire c'est c'est
vraiment non non j'ai eu personne très
longtemps moi j'avais rien même une fois
vous voyez je vais vous dire une chose
parce que on on on ne se rend pas compte
de de la de la lutte on se rend pas
compte de de la tristesse on se rend pas
compte de l'épreuve de des gens qui
physiquement ne sont pas gâtés ils
souffrent énormément ils souffrent parce
que ils ils ont un cœur comme les autres
ça c'est ça qui est terrible et un jour
n'ayant rien sous la main
j'aperçois dans dans un film une fille
qui était assistante mais vraiment
l'IDE vraiment l'IDE et je me dis alors
là tu as peut-être ta chance et bien
elle m'a refusé mais mais
elle m'a dit
non mais vous avez eu quand même vous
avez eu des conquêtes Michel dès que
j'ai eu une situation ça a mieux marché
c'est ça que je voulais vous dire ah
c'est ça la chute la célébrité rend dès
que j'ai eu une situation ça a bien
marchant mais oui excusez-moi comment il
était il y a 40 ans parce que là il se
décrit lui mais comment vous le voyez il
était comme ça plutôt réservé timide oh
non oh non il était plus un peu plus
calme là vraiment il s'extériorise il
était seulement un tout petit peu plus
CLAL mais sinon c'est le même homme oui
oui c'est sûr et c'est c'est toujours
celui qu'on adore
d'ailleurs dans le film oh quelle chance
voilà oui non mais et vous vraiment les
hommes à vos pieds non non RA pas elle
la vra pas mais non elle dira pas oh il
y en avait quelquesuns mais ou pas
beaucoup ah mais non mais les gens ils
en jamais assez
mais comment vous avez été choisi
comment vous êtes retrouver sur le
tournage des
gendarmes y en a eu plusieurs les
gendarmes moi c'est c'est la femme de de
finess qui m'a parce que je ne jouais
que des rôles tu te tiens un peu à moi
quand tu parles
trop je ne jouais que des rôle
dramatique surtout à la télévision et
une fois j'ai joué un rôle comique dans
la dame de chez Maxime de Féo Louis
definess et sa femme sont venus voir la
pièce et ils m'ont dit mais on savait
pas que tu jouais des rôles comiques et
ben je dit moi non plus et voilà et
c'est comme ça que ça a commencer et
vous bon moi j'étais j'étais à Saint-
tropé ma femme m'avait amené à Saint-
tropé parce que
queelle oui c'était ma première femme
elle voulait aller absolument à Saint
tropé parce que elle disait dans les
gazettes dans les journaux people ça a
toujours ça existe encore maintenant des
choses il y avait Brigitte bardau il y
avait il y avait Vadim il y avait tout
une faune on s'amusait beaucoup il
fallait y aller couchais à l'Hôtel De La
ponche c'était l'hôtel à la mode aussi
le matin jour la fenêtre et je vois
terrasse je vois des types qui bavardent
on entendait c'était une belle il disent
voilà alors vous m'engagez deux funesses
hein et après je veux des ringards je ne
veux pas les payer hein vous avez bien
compris que je veux des ringar je me
tourne vers ma femme en disant et ben
celui qui va être engagé évidemment et
ben c'était moi voilà vous n'étiez pas
connu à l'époque et de funess c'était
une immense vedette non pas encore il
était immense immense voilà c'est moi
non il avait il me rappelle toujours le
cachet qu'il avait il avait vu 8
millions ancien ce premier caché et moi
j'avais 6000 francs C en 60 mais bon ça
faisait pas beaucoup quand même mais
c'est ce qui vous a lancé ah oui ben
c'est ce qui nous a lancé c'est c'est
c'est de funesses nous devons tout à de
funesses faut biener parce que il a
éclab pardon il nous a éclabousséous a
éclaboussé ça c'est très joli ce qu'elle
dit il nous a éclaboussé ah je savais
pas que tu pouvais sortir
des c'est très beau c'est très beau ce
que tu viens dire oui exactement on a on
a recueilli un peu des des des choses de
sa gloire quelques quelques pépites
voilà et c'est une image les gendarmes
qui vous a collé à la peau souvent et
longtemps ah toujours oh je crois que de
toute façon toujours c'est un délibile
oui moi je senttis avec un KPI peut-être
toi peut-être pas
mais et pourquoi vous n'avez tourné
qu'avec de funesses vous parce que
j'estimis je jouais au théâtre le soir
et je tournais le jour avec lui et je
trouvais qu'un film par an c'est
suffisant et luoui m'avait dit au 4e
film que j'ai tourné avec lui il m'a dit
tu devrais accepter d'autres rôles avec
d'autres metteurs en scène parce que on
va te cataloguer oh pensestu c'est pas
vrai tellement quand la réussite est
patente quand la réussie c'est grande
évidemment il y a un inconvénient c'est
que c'est fini on dit c'est elle là
c'est tout c'était la femme de de fun
quand Louis est
mort on va en même temps
et il y a pas longtemps un des mteur en
scène m'a dit oh ben je croyais que vous
vouliez plus faire de cinéma qu'est-ce
que vous avez répondu rien je suis
restée tétanisé par tant de connerie
mais heureusement pour moi je faisais de
la télé et puis et du et du théâtre
votre plus beau rôle celui dont vous
êtes le plus fier en dehors du juge et
de l'assassin don parass parce que vous
étiez un assassin d'ailleurs formidable
oui oui oui oui Mo je sais pas cinéma
cinéma c'est le metteur en scène he ça
ils font ils font il font peut faire
venettre un chien la fidèle la ciretin
mais votre plus beau souvenir mon plus
beau souvenir c'est les gendarmes moi ça
reste les gendarmes B oui ma rencontre
avec CLUD jeensac mais des films
justement vous appelez les nanards vous
en avez tourné vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup oui beaucoup mais vous avez
tourné tous ces films hein pour des
raisons alimentaires parce qu' on ne
vous proposait que ça
mais bien entendu je pas assez con pour
refuser quand quand Tavernier m'a
proposé le juge d' assassin j'ai attendu
un an je me suis mis au chômage pour pas
louper le truc tu pas idiot pas idiot
mais je vais vous raconter une anecdote
s'ils en voulaient à un moment donné au
mois d'avril au mois de mai ma femme ma
femme et mes deux enfants me disent ils
étaient tout petits j'avais une jeune
fille au père et ma femme me dit alors
on va en vacances
où où va en vacances il y avait rien il
y a rien juste un petit rôle de maître
Jacques dans laavare dans un festival
c'est tout ce que j'avais comme
perspective et brusquement un navé s'est
présenté une histoire de chat
épouvantable sur la Côte
d'Azur j'ai signé et quand j'ai vu ma
femme mes enfants et la jeune fille
auère se mettre en maillot de bain parce
que j'avais pu leur payer la petite
maison au bord de la mer j'ai été
glorieux j'étais joyeux et le navé que
j'ai fait je lui suis reconnaissant on
rit et en même temps l'image est
magnifique et émouvante de voir oui
votre famille comme ça avoir des vacan
ça après c'était une histoire de chat
les chats étaient nous nous en voulent
il nous griffer ils avaient c'était
horrible mais il n'y avait pas que moi
qui avait accepté ce film le film n'est
jamais sorti tellement il était mauvais
mais il y avait pas que moi avvec Gabie
Morley qui était une des très grandes
actrices Claude jeansac vous avez aussi
accepté des films comme ça alimentaires
comme comme Michel
a lui parce que comme j'étais au théâtre
je pouvais me permettre de de refuser
quelques quelques nanard mais ça m'est
arrivé oui deux trois fois vous savez
les comédiens c'est c'est nous sommes
des intermittents ça va ça bien nous
sommes nous sommes au téléphone cone les
ça sonne ou ça ne sonne pas et
quand ça ne sonne pas on ne mange pas au
moins vous appelez les parceil y a
quelques acteurs qui sont ban bol
c'est-à-dire que on fait un film sur eux
et alors là le le les dollars pleuvent
mais les autres il sont beaucoup moins
payés et c'est aléatoire et en même
temps très généreux je crois on dit de
vous grand cœur vous oh on dit ce qu'on
veut percé ouais j'ai un peu percé oui
il a percé un peu mais ça bon parce que
vous dites il a fallu payer les divorces
les pensions alimentaires et cetera mais
finalement vous n'avez divorcé qu'une
fois oui oui d'accord oui d'accord mais
bon moi j'ai vu une pensée comme ça il a
dit tip dit je me suis je suis remarié
c'est pas la seconde qui coûte cher
c'est la
[Musique]
première les femmes coûtent cher aux
hommes je ne sais pas ben n sait rien
pas est pas hommes hein non moi je crois
qu'en tout cas que les femmes qui
travaillent et qui gardent bien leur
vie c'est les hommes qui leur coûte cher
alors c'est pour ça que j'ai divorcé
deux fois les hommes vous ont coûté cher
vous ah en fait c'est le même alors
c'est le même discours vous voyez et ben
oui et c'est un paradoxe oui et je ne
sais pas jusqu'à quel point en tout cas
pour le
second le second mari ça l'ennuyait
beaucoup que moi je gagne très bien ma
vie ah ça vous allez l'embêé et alors il
me prenait tout mon argent et les hommes
ça a été votre faiblesse Claude euh oui
mais j'ai eu la chance de ne pas être
amoureuse ah tuétais pas amoureuse ah
non tu t'es marié sans amour alors oui
avec beaucoup de tendresse mais sans
amour ah tu étais pas amoureuse mais
est-ce que tu jamais été amoureuse cl
non non ah non de votre vie
h c'est
incroyable contente parce que j'aurais
été très malheureuse si on m'avait
quitté ah là là ça ça tu es spécial ça
c'est il
faudit quel chose qui va pas
là j'ai AG comme un homme j'ai agi comme
un homme ah oui ah mais les hommes ils
sont amoureux tu dis que tu as pas été
amoureuse les hommes sont très moi
j'étais très à être
malade pendant 2 ans je pouvais plus
vivre j'étais au bord du suicide moi
j'ai très amoureux parce que dit é non
non je suis pas venu pour rien parce que
moi je suis passionné de psychologie une
femme qui était très belle et qui n'a
pas été amoureuse et qui s'est marié qui
et s'est marié avec des cé
extraordinaire et d'autres et d'autres
étaient là qui qui qui qui qui qui qui
comment dirais-je qui en bavit devant
cette femme qui était belle qui était
qui était surtout
sexuelx pas on n'est pas obligé d'être
amoureux on peut avoir de la tendresse
pour mais on est d'abord amoureux on a
des coups de F vous n'avez jamais
éprouvé ce sentiment que c'est vrai que
c'est c'est la première fois c'est la
première fois j'is où j'avais envie d'un
homme ou alors j'avais de la tendresse
pour un homme mais tu avais envie salors
sexuellement bah bien sûr
jeuse sinon oh et moi qui avait
envie de
toi vous auriez dû vous vous auriez dû
vous parler que vous n'avez pas affaire
à de intello là moi je trouve ça très je
trouve
h intéress regardez là regardez là on a
un bavé et alors moi je vais vous dire
je vais vous faire un aveu
elle était était mariée avec Pierre
Mandi alors elle était mariée avec Alain
Delong c'est pas la peine d'assister
mais elle était avec Mandi on peut
espérer rivaliser c'est gentil pour mon
dit mais je le dis franchement il est
pas mal mon dit mais il est pas mieux
que moi
ou un peu mieux c'est tout c'est tout
c'est tout c'est tout peut-être que
jeispous par
peut-être que je t'aurais épousé si il
est pas mieux que moi il est pas mal
mais il est pas mieux que moii jeis te
dire j'ai
épousé expqu deux hommes parce qu'ils
m'ont fait
rire si je t'avais connu plutôt je
te'urais sûrement épousé c'est pas drôle
l'amour on peut pas se fendre la gueule
parce qu'on est amoureux c'est les
femmes sont très curiux ell les aiment
parce que le type la fait rire bah oui
c'est la première des choses demande à
toutes les femmes elles ve rire ce qui
intéresse une femme d'abord chez un
homme sauf le quand elles ont affaire à
des bélâes machin c'est que le mec les
fasse rire
oui mais alors si je comprends bien
alors vous il n'y a que le désir et puis
après la tende la tendresse mais ça
c'est pour après et au
milieu pendant tout de suite la tend
c'est tendresse et la sexualité c'est
tout pas
d'amour cela dit cela dit écoutez
écoutez Claude ce que me disait quand
même Michel il y a deux ou 3 ans je
crois que les les murs du studio s'en
souviennent encore on vous
écoute c'est la bête avec le désir
immonde parce que la sexualité c'est une
calamité c'est là c'est la preuve de
l'existence de Dieu la sexualité c'est
terrible parce que ça fait faire des
bêtises ça fait faire des crimes ça fait
faire des vols ça fait faire des
meurtres âge je la je le dis à tous vous
serez délivré le calme l'apaisement mais
alors jusque-là un garçon a le feu entre
les jambes le
feu et tu joues la tragédie
magnifiquement oui c'est formidable oh
mais moi je suis quand même intéressant
merde mais vous trouvez qu'il exagère ou
qu'il a raison dans ce qu'il dit non il
exagère un peu quand même donc vous êtes
content finalement le temps passant de
vous assagir Michel ou oui parce que ah
oui ah
ouiff oui oui oui oui mais maintenant je
suis très tranquille moi je un petit
cigare voyez ma télé je bouge pas c'est
pas pas inquier autrefois à un moment
donné PAF l'éruption arrivé il fallait
trouver il fallait trouver alors on
payit je pay avant tu aller au je
payé oui fait toutes les de Paris
ah bon mexcuse de te décevoir mais si tu
m'avais aidé ah non mais c'est pas ça me
déçoit pas spécialement non f on va voir
ce qu'on veut ah voir tout
put cela dit dans vos mémoires vous
disiez que votre père aussi était un un
cha lapin un sacré
cavaleur ça vient peut-être de là et de
la souffrance qu' a eu ma mère parce que
ma mère a été très malheureuse donc pas
confiance finalement j'avais 5 6 ans et
un jour j'ai dit à ma mère tu veux que
j'aille dire à papa qu'il soit plus
gentil avec
toi
mais le pautip il pouvait rien
ça je n'ai jamais été amoureuse je pense
que c'est venu de là et donc un regret
de ça d'avoir vécu cette vie-là sans
amour Claude ou finalement c'estétait
bien finalement la tendresse dans c'tait
très bien c'était très bien voyez moi je
voyez que mon côté le côté de l'homme et
là voilà moi je m' voilà vous ah dépens
vous toujours en couple avec votre é ou
ouiouou ouii oui oui oui oui oui et et
quel paèire quel paèire alors vous êtes
ah moi vous savez c'est mon père me le
reprocher je suis copain un peu copain
et mon père me dit tu Michel méfie-toi
tu tu le pér ben non non je suis copain
avec mes enfants plutôt oui et vous très
protecteur hein avec vos enfants pas
envie l'un et l'autre de retraite d'être
justement tranquillement chez vous avec
maisà je so on s'emmerde
mais de toute façon vous savez 2 mois si
je me repose pendant 2 mois c'est
formidable mais ça suffit c'est vrai
après vous ennuyez ah oui terriblement
c'est formidable cette femme là vous
dites-moi mais regardez elle c'est
pareil nous sommes nous sommes des des
passionnés on aime notre méti par que
vous prenez la parole toujours ah non
c'est pas vrai je gueule mais elle a
parlé vous n pas minuté non autant point
oui as vous coupez vous machin he après
a c'est pas sûr que peut-être que j'irai
de beau c'est tout et que toi tu parles
tout le temps si elle veut si elle veut
biray on est foutu
ah Michel Michel alors au bout du compte
vous avez réalisé tous vos rêves non
mais vous plaisantez non rien du
tout tout non non rien du tout je
voulais pas faire ça je voulais non non
c'est c'est c'est je ne me plains pas
parce que j'ai eu de la chance il dans
ce métier faut avoir de la chance c'est
convenable c'est convenable plus mais
c'est pas ça mais c'est pas ça mais
c'est pas ça toujours humble he Claude
oui c'est de la fausse modestie moi je
dirais oui mais c'est tout ce que vous
voulez je m'en fous mais qu'est-ce qu'il
vous c'est qu'est-ce qu'il vous man ah
ben j'aurais aimé être ce qu'on appelle
une grande Venette un banque c'est la
grande Venette c'est pas moi la vraie
Venette c'est la banque et bol
c'està-dire qu'on fait un film sur vous
parce que vous rapportez de l'argent
vous voyez ce que je veux dire alors là
tu en connais beaucoup ah bah il y en a
toujours dans un dans un pays il y en a
4 C il y a 4 C banqu et bol nous on n
jamais été banqu et bol ma pauvre ça se
serait su c'est-à-dire un film qui qui
se montre uniquement sur votre nom ah
oui oui oui oui c'est-à-dire bah de
funet c'était ban et bol Belmondo était
banque bol Fernandel était banque bol ça
vous plaît he ce mot ban b b ça sent ça
sent le
poon on y revient toujours les problèmes
d'argent avec Michel
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Inna
Mireille Guma abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche